sur le lien porno prostitution il ya
quand même une différence notable qui
est quand même celle de l'image et c'est
vrai que les raisons qui peuvent amener
à faire de la pornographie pour pour les
pour les femmes sont assez différents de
la pression on peut être aussi beaucoup
dans un rapport d'estimé de soi de 2
de se donner aussi une existence
médiatique
toutes ces choses là qui n'existe pas
dans la prostitution et qu'il faut bien
et qu'il faut bien avoir en tête et
c'est vrai que aussi pour certaines
femmes c'est ça peut être aussi un moyen
de ces panneaux peints de s'épanouir et
on peut pas le nier c'est vrai que voilà
moi une actrice qui me racontait son
enfance passée dans les foyers avec un
père incestueux ce genre de choses est
qui et qui finalement à 25 ans peut
voyager partout en europe aller dans des
fêtes aller dans des endroits sympas
belle aux dîmes finalement moi cette vie
comment j'aurais pu avoir accès à tout
ça sans son ensemble la pornographie et
elle me dit moi ça me prend je préfère
ça que d'être agent de nettoyage et bon
bah il faut il faut évidemment
l'entendre donc donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils voient là c'est quand même il ya
quand même cette différence avec avec la
prostitution qui est assez forte il faut
aussi voir sur les sur les salons du x
la notoriété concon certaines de ces
femmes qui sont totalement inconnu pour
nous mais vraiment des starlettes jackie
et michel confais confié une quinzaine
de scènes il va avoir des hommes qui
vont faire dix minutes de queue pour
avoir un autographe il ya aussi tous eu
toute cette valorisation
qui est très importante à avoir en tête
pour comprendre pourquoi pour pourquoi
est elle sincère dans dans ces parcours
et aussi pour comme je le dis toujours
aux gens essayer de changer la
perspective et ne pas voir que ces
femmes comme comme des victimes mais
vraiment de s'intéresser pourquoi les
hommes commettent commerce et a vu qu'en
fait c'est vraiment ça de façon le
locker le coeur du sujet elles elles
font elles font souvent comme elles
peuvent
[Musique]